okay we did a story late last week about
Jill Stein it was a critical story about
Jill Stein I mentioned I know I'm going
to get hate for doing this but everybody
here knows that if there's one thing
that is a constant on the David Pakman
show it's that I'm always up front with
you and I always tell you the truth is I
see it and the truth is I believe it and
what I'm feeling and thinking about any
issue at any particular time I'm not
gonna hide the fact that I think that
the entire Jill Stein situation stinks
so I did a story about the 7 million
dollars that she raised for supposed
recounts after the 2016 election the
blowback was significant there were
people who were very very happy with me
for doing that story but there were also
people who were very very angry with me
for doing that story so here's just a
sampling okay here's one voicemail I
received about my Jill Stein story last
week hey David as a voter for Jill Stein
here in California I got to say that
after your reporting
I read after your reporting about Jill
Stein I read some reports on it
elsewhere and I think you're right I
think Jill science just I might be doing
a little bit of corruption here and I
kind of really regret that vote now so
yeah there you go so right right that
was one set right that was one camp that
said I'm really glad you did that story
and I'm glad you're not avoiding
criticism of people on the left for
whatever reason here's another side
people who had a very very different
point of view why can you say that Jill
Stein ran a crappy campaign but you
can't say that Hillary ran a crappy
campaign why is that
have it oh and by the way you all your
hate mail Patriot mails sound like
they're written by the same guy I think
people who don't like your show don't
watch your show and don't take time to
write hate great nails I think they're
all written by the same guy totally
wrong and you're paying the guy who
writes them not paying anybody yeah okay
I don't care about that
I've criticized Hillary Clinton I
ventured to say comfortably hundreds if
not thousands of times oh right I mean
who I I'm at a loss for words I'm at a
loss for words we have a great bonus
show for you today we will be talking
about AIDS
seeking a new apartment for Scott Pruett
and an old mattress from a Trump Hotel
very very unusual we will also review a
new report which says much to Pat's
dismay that there is no evidence that
having sex with robots is healthy it's
just not healthy Pat okay there's no
benefits to that and also a new gun
study which says that permit laws for
guns reduce murders and that red flag
laws cut suicides those stories and much
more on today's bonus show do we want to
say it do we want to preview anything
about the upcoming chess match I think
we can yeah we have the time do we have
the time I you control the time I'm
wasting time now by wondering whether we
have time then we don't have time no no
listen we are gonna be doing so I
mentioned that I've been playing chess
on chess calm despite being terrible at
it and there has been demand from the
audience for a Pat versus David chess
match but what we decided is that it's
going to be a Pat and Max versus David
chess match it is going to be
live-streamed once we get to 2,000
patrons on patreon and we will make a
formal announcement tomorrow we will
discuss the logistics of it and I think
it's gonna be a huge thing yeah and I'm
not a chess master by any means but I've
started my training and I think the
audience will be impressed you've
watched searching for Bobby Fischer a
few times is that what you mean that's
it yeah all right so we'll talk about
that tomorrow great bonus show join
pakman.com to get access and we will
talk to you in just a few minutes